Okay.
Denise Lee Yohn, thank you so much
for being on my show.
How are you?
I'm good.
Thank you so much for having me.
I am extremely excited to have you.
Brand leadership, culture, messaging,
best selling author of Fusion,
and What Great Brands Do.
You assist so many different companies
on their brand leadership
and messaging and culture
that I'm so excited to pick your brain
in the next 20 minutes
on what that even means.
Can you tell me
a little bit about yourself
and what is branding in general?
Yeah, yeah.
Well, so the number one thing
you need to know about me
is that I love brands.
I've been very passionate about brands,
not only as a consumer or customer,
I have my favorite brands,
but as a professional.
I really try to understand
how brands really engage people,
seduce people,
invite people into their community,
into their world, and people,
both customers and employees
and other partners.
And so, you ask me
about the definition of branding,
and I actually, frankly,
don't use the term branding.
Because I think that, branding,
if you think about where it came,
where the term came from, it was when,
back when people had cattle and ranches
and they would brand their cows
with their logos
so that people would know
that the cows belong to them.
And that's really not what is necessary
or appropriate or compelling
in today's [--].
We're not putting our logos on things
just so that people know
who owns it or who it belongs to.
What I consider to be brand building
is much more about
what you do and how you do it.
So, it really becomes very much
a part of your business strategy
and your operations,
and to your point,
your culture and your organization.
So, why is this even a topic
that needs discussion?
Why do so many people
and companies struggle with
exactly what you're talking about?
Yeah. Well, I think a lot of companies
still do think about their branding,
so they'd think about:
what should our name be,
what should our logo look like,
what should our website look like,
what should our colors be,
and all of that things are important
because we are communicating
and trying to engage people
through communications.
But if you don't have
the strategic foundation
of what you stand for,
what your values are,
how you're engaging your employees
to deliver great customer experiences,
and what is your differentiation
and all of that,
then you really don't have a brand.
You don't have something
that is meaningful and valuable
and that really can create
that connection for you.
Talk to me a bit about your journey.
How do you even get started with
becoming passionate about this topic
and helping others then overcome it?
Yeah.
So, I studied liberal arts background.
And in college I was a psychology,
political science double major.
And my first job out of school
was in marketing.
I was a market research analyst.
And so, my first few jobs
were really foundational,
in a sense of learning in market research,
learning to understand
how consumers made decisions
and how companies
could communicate with them
to influence those decisions.
I also did some product management.
So, really figuring out
how do you research and develop products
and how you bring them to market.
And then I worked
in the advertising agency
to really figure out how do you create
the creative communications
and the engagement with customers.
And out of all those experiences,
Sony Electronics recruited me
and I end up starting up
their first ever brand office.
Wow.
And it was there at Sony,
that I really learned so much
about the value of internal
organizational alignment and engagement.
At the time, this is back in the 90s,
so I'm definitely dating myself,
but Sony had just started
to see some chinks in the armor
as Apple was rising.
And the thing about Apple is that
their emotional connection
and their ability to just create
this relationship with their customers
is so powerful.
And Sony definitely wanted
to compete on that.
But without the internal understanding
of how were we going to do that,
what does Sony really stand for,
what do we really have to offer,
we couldn't compete
on speeds and feeds anymore
because Apple and other players,
definitely, were doing
[--].
So, what was that emotional connection
that we create.
And we, internally within Sony, didn't have
one common understanding of that.
There was no way we were going to build
to deliver on that externally.
So, I learned a lot about that at Sony.
And then for a variety of reasons,
which I can tell you
over a drink sometime,
I end up resigning my job
and starting my own brand consultancy
where I can start consulting practice.
And do that for quite a few years,
had some opportunities
to work on these great brands
that you were referring to.
And then over time have really shifted
from doing a lot of consulting
and a little bit of speaking and writing,
to doing mostly speaking and writing
and then just a little bit of consulting.
Right. So now, getting this message across
and helping others understand
engagement better and culture.
And then why is engagement difficult
internally within a company?
So, I'm now asking
as a young entrepreneur,
as I go through my journey
of hopefully building a company
and thinking about culture myself
and growing the team,
I now get to be a part of 8200
in 70 person team
in the hypergrowth company
and seeing the culture,
what are some pitfalls
that the leaders make
when they're trying to engage
both their consumers
but also their employees?
And then, what are some important things
to keep in mind?
Yeah. Well, actually,
a lot happens in that journey
that you just described.
Because I think that when you were small
and just starting up,
you and your co-founders probably have
a really clear vision
on what you want to stand for
and the kind of company
you want to create.
But I think that,
often what happens is either:
a, you take that for granted
and as you add more people
you just assume that everyone gets it;
and or B, you get so consumed
with operations and development
and really trying to build a business
that those things overtake your desire
to create this great organization.
And so, in the scaling process,
you lose that focus on
really what are we about
and really what are we creating.
And so then you wake up one day,
and like you say
you have 200 employees and you're like,
oh my gosh, and our culture sucks.
And you were competing
in this brutal war for talent
and we are trying to offer
an experience to our employees
that may or may not be competitive.
And so, I think that you really need to,
as a leader of your organization,
as one of the people
who's driving the growth,
you need to be very intensely focused
on prioritizing culture building.
Understand it doesn't just happen.
And we need to be
not only talking about it all the time
to make sure that you're clear
on the kind of culture you want
and the kind of organization you want,
but then also role modeling that culture.
So, you can't just be all words.
You need to be action.
And then finally that,
you are actually designing
and running the organization
to cultivate that kind of culture.
So, which departments
or which groups in your company
need to be working together better
or you need to make sure
there's really tight alignment integration
and make sure that you're cultivating that
in the way that you run the organization.
Are there certain employee experiences
or employee rituals or artifacts
or policies and procedures,
all of these things
you need to be thinking about
as you put those in place
to make sure that they represent
and really support and advance
your desired culture.
So, culture building really
is a strategic leadership responsibility
that you as a founder
or as an entrepreneur
need to be accepting that responsibility
and championing it.
I think that's fascinating.
I heard you speak
at a few other occurrences
and a lot of the times,
it's this idea that, yeah,
we can put posters on the wall
that scream our culture and our messaging.
But then actions speak louder than words.
And when I think about brand
and when I think about
what a company expresses,
people always think outside of the company,
how are outside consumers
going to interact with our products.
But then, I think people also forget,
and I sometimes forget that at the end
it's the people building these products
have to live by these experiences
and by these messages
so that they can develop the products
that other people will be happy about.
What are some common themes
that you're seeing as startups are scaling,
with the pitfalls that leaders are making
as they're losing out of the culture?
Is it simply that they forget
or do other things come in the way?
Yeah. Well, oftentimes
they'll delegate it to someone.
So, again, as a founder or leader,
you've got lots of responsibilities.
And so, you think,
"I can't do everything."
"I'm going to hire good people
to work for me."
And certainly,
you need to have a strong goal
to execute your strategies
and to help you implement your tactics.
But you can't, as a leader,
ever abdicate your responsibility
for culture building.
And if you don't give, let's say you have
a head of employee experience
or head of HR,
if you don't give them the tools
and investment and resources they need
to create this great employee experience,
they're going to be hamstrung.
And so, their effectiveness
is very much tied to your buy into this.
So, it's really important for you
to make sure that
you are continuing to lead.
The other things, I think,
is to understand that
your values as an organization
need to be woven
into everything that you do.
Again, like I said,
they can't just be words on a page.
But you need to be applying them,
especially to your people decisions:
who to hire, who to fire,
who to promote, who to develop.
And you need to be using your values
as a filter or as a screen
for your people,
not only because that will make sure
that you have the right people
on the right positions
doing the right work,
but that's also probably
one of the most important
or most influential ways
that you share your values
with the organization.
If someone sees you saying that
creativity and risk taking is important,
but you are always penalizing people
when they fail
or you're actually firing people
because they failed or they took a risk
and it didn't turn out,
then people are going to be like,
"Well, wait a minute."
That value that you were talking about
doesn't really seem
to be a reality, really.
Also you need to be thinking,
okay, if this is the kind of value
that I want to have my organization,
the best way to show
that I mean what I say
is in my decisions about people.
100%. And I think it also speaks
to the hire slow, fire fast.
This idea that think about the people
that are in the company,
they're not just skillful people
that are getting things done,
but every hire
is going to impact the culture.
And obviously,
the higher up in the ladder you go,
the more critical it is.
What are some incredible things
that you've seen people do
in order to create good engagement
with their employees
or their customers outside?
Some things that
I might not even be thinking of
as I'm growing my own company.
I get a lot of examples from Airbnb
because I did a deep dive
into that organization
when I wrote my book, FUSION.
And so, they created
an employee experience department
where they brought in
all the different functions
that impact an employees,
their day to day experience,
and brought them together under one person
and into one consolidated group,
which meant that they were looking
at the employee experience
the way that you look
at a customer experience,
like the journey that employee has
throughout their tenure.
And so, they started
their employee experience
during recruiting, where in addition
to all of the functional screens
that someone has to go through
as a potential worker,
who also are interviewed twice
just based on values.
And that way
the company really gets to know
what your values are
and gets to assess
whether there's alignment
with the company's values.
And what's really interesting is:
a, that these values interviews
are not done by the hiring manager,
they're done by members of a committee
specifically designated
towards values reviews;
and two, if they decide
that this candidate
is not a fit culturally
or is not aligned to the values,
they can actually override the hiring,
even though those person could be
absolutely the right skills,
right experience,
the company is not going to hire them.
So, I mean, it's like having a very
prescriptive, strict standards
that enables a company like Airbnb
to attract the kind of people
who really believe in the mission
and who work by the values.
And then on the back side,
in the recent months,
Airbnb had to lay off a lot of employees.
Yes.
And the way that they've done so,
in the letter from Brian Chesky,
just the humanity
and the compassion and empathy
that was demonstrated through that
is another sign of how seriously
the company takes the employee experience
and [--].
Definitely. 100%
So, you made a conscious decision yourself
to transition your experience from that
of building the brand of a certain company
and culture of a certain company
to now looking in the broader picture
about a lot of different companies.
So, first of all,
I'd love to hear about this transition.
And why are you so excited
about the work that you're doing now?
Yeah. Well, I felt like
I could have a lot more impact
on a lot more companies
if I were to increase
my speaking business
and increased my writing,
and really just try
to get my ideas out more.
When you work for a single company
or when you do
the kind of brand consulting
that I first was doing
when I first came out of Sony,
there is deep dive into the organization.
And so, you can really affect change
within that one organization.
But I felt like I was limited in a way,
and especially because,
unlike maybe the folks
who are listening to this interview,
I wasn't going to grow a big company.
It was just going to be me.
I wasn't going to have any employees.
And the rate limiting factor
is my bandwidth.
So, if I were to impact
the most people that I can,
it's going to have to be
through speaking and writing.
And it turns out that I think
when I did a lot of self-examination
about what I got excited about
and what I found life-giving,
what I felt like I really wanted
to get better and better at,
like it was a passion of mine
to really hone my skills set,
it was speaking.
It was really getting out there
in front of people and figure out
how do I share what's in my head
and all the research and experience
that I've had
and be able to communicate that
in a way that they understand.
That's just fascinating to me.
100%.
So, that's what gets me up
every day, really.
I love it.
I did love that challenge.
So, alongside that messaging,
so Fusion, What Great Brands Do,
tell me a little bit about each book
and what I can expect to find in there.
And maybe one or two nuggets
that we can extrapolate from each.
Yeah. Yeah.
So, What Great Brands Do,
the seven brand building principles
that separates the best from the rest.
Now this book came out in 2014
so some of the examples
are a little bit dated,
but I continue to hear from people today
how informative these seven principles are
because it really takes with you
some counter-intuitive practices
of brand building.
Like great brands avoid selling products.
Like they don't push products on people
promote features in a top-tier technology.
They're much more, as I said earlier,
into the business of seducing people
and incline people in it
and making an emotional connection.
As my book shows you how to do that
gives you some tools
to bring what's in
lots of case studies and examples.
Right.
My second book, Fusion:
How Integrating Brand and Culture
Powers The World's Greatest Companies,
is about how you take
your internal organizational culture
and your external brand identity
and ensure that they are
mutually reinforcing
and definitely integrated and aligned
and intertwined in such a way
that you really are on the inside
what you say on the outside.
Because then, not only do you engage
your people really effectively,
but you pass the customer test
of brand authenticity.
Because these days,
customers want to know
really what's behind the curtain
and they have the ability to find out.
So, you want to make sure that
how you're operating the organization
really is with integrity and authenticity.
So, I highly recommend those two books.
And then I will say
for your audience in particular,
I've written a small book called,
parts of the paper really,
a change this manifesto
about minimum viable brand.
It's all based
on the minimal viable product.
Yeah.
But given that you're going to have
limited resources and limited time
when you're first starting out,
what are the few things
that you need to make sure
that you have in place
as you're building your brand.
And so, all of these things
can be found on my website
and hopefully they'll be good resources
for your folks.
100%. I think, everything you talked about
is just fascinating.
I think that today, especially in 2020,
and we've seen it especially this year,
how important company culture is
both in terms of adapting to lay offs
and a lot of the stuff
that's been coming out over recent years
in company culture is, I think,
things that people in my years of studying
and people in my age group
that are starting companies
we're very very conscious of.
And we're always thinking,
okay, from day zero,
how do we get the right culture.
And just the other day,
my good friend who has just finished
the Stanford Business School, he asked me,
"Michael, what is going to be your schtick
as a CEO?"
"I'm going to be the Nature CEO,
and that's the culture
that I want to build in my company."
And people are thinking
of what types of the niche markets
they like to address and what type
of cultures and communities
they want to build,
I think that's amazing.
I know that in the company
that I'm with now, Hippo Insurance,
the culture is incredible.
And I'm really I'm fascinated
to sit next to the CEO
and I get to talk to him about the way
that he addresses these problems.
And every onboarding process
is a new adventure and a new celebration
by over 200 people,
which is just incredible.
But Denise, before we leave,
I have to ask you
the most important question,
three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Yeah, you know, Michael,
that's such a hard question.
It's the hardest one.
And I don't prepare enough.
So, I'm sorry as well.
So, I have two and maybe a third one
will come to me.
So, definitely driven.
So, I'll go with this driven.
I am definitely like someone
who sees a goal, sets a goal,
goes after it.
And two, I'm very disciplined.
In the sense that
I can have my way of doing things.
My whole life is arranged in a way
so that I can achieve my goals.
And so, those are the two.
I don't know the third one.
I'm not sure, I would say maybe
this is more than one word,
but since I'm doing the [--],
I'm dedicated to my faith
in the sense that I'm a person of faith
and I really am guided by my faith.
And so, that provides the center
and the core for me.
So, I could have cheated
and use more than one word
on that last one.
That's perfectly fine.
I'm disciplined and dedicated
to my faith.
Denise, thank you very very much.
This is fascinating.
I can't wait to read these books myself.
It sounds like it's something
that's incredibly insightful
for any young entrepreneur or any leader
that wants to affect change
in their own community,
whether it's in a company
or whether it's in the simple community,
in their family or whatever it is.
It sounds like it's relevant
for a lot of different things
besides business.
Thank you very very much, Denise.
I really appreciate it.
Stay safe and stay healthy.
Bye bye.